se arrastra por conducto de
ventilación oscuro. Llega a sala de
mando secreta, luces rojas, monos con
auriculares mirando pantallas gigantes.
saca platanófono y graba escena.
Abajo, Monjefe señala mapa de la jungla
entera. Dice, "Platanael va a dominar la
economía mundial. se sorprende y
Platanófono cae al suelo. Guardias Mono
se alertan y ven mono escondido detrás
de rejilla de ventilación. corre,
pero guardas lo atrapan y encierran en
Sala Oscura. quiere entender que
vio exactamente, cómo jungla tan pequeña
puede dominar economía mundial, qué ha
hecho Platanael para conseguir
tecnología más avanzada de mundo y cuál
es plan definitivo para dominar economía
mundial. Hoy Mono explica todo. Paradoja
del tamaño. Platanael suena grande, pero
solo 540,000 millones de hojas verdes en
PIP. Eso es todo. Hasta Plataña tiene
más. Económicamente Platanael es
minúsculo, apenas 0,5% de toda economía
mundial, tan pequeño como hilos blancos
de plátano que a mono no gusta comer.
Pero aquí viene sorpresa. 20% de
economía de jungla es hightech, suena
normal, pero 50% de todas exportaciones
ser tecnología pura. Eso se llama
hiperconcentración. Es Mono que pone
todos sus plátanos en una sola cesta.
Mono busca quién compra tecnología a
Platanael. Abre lista de clientes, ve
nombres grandes, Google, Microsoft,
Nvidia, Apple, Amazon, Meta, Intel,
empresas más poderosas de jungla global.
¿Por qué empresas tan fuertes gastan
tantas hojas verdes en jungla minúscula?
Porque Platanael tiene algo raro, algo
que no se puede copiar fácil. Software
que protege datos de empresas más
grandes. Monos ingenieros de otras
junglas llevan décadas intentando
fabricar, pero no consiguen. Platanael
no domina por tamaño, domina porque sin
su tecnología máquinas de grandes
empresas no funcionan, sistemas colapsan
y empresas más grandes de jungla global
saben que no tienen otra opción. Ahora
Mono ya sabe que Platanael vende
tecnología, sabe que empresas más
grandes de jungla global la compran,
pero no sabe por qué no pueden
fabricarla ellas mismas. Porque con
todas las hojas verdes que tienen, con
todos sus monos ingenieros, siguen
viniendo a Platanael a comprar ciber
jungla. Platanael tiene 434 centros de
investigación de empresas más grandes de
mundo en jungla de tamaño de plátano.
Google tiene equipo allí. Microsoft
también, Nvidia, Apple, todas. No porque
les guste clima, sino porque ahí están
cerebros de monos que no encuentran en
ningún otro sitio. Pero mono necesita
número para entenderlo de verdad. Marzo
2026. Google compra Wi por 32,000ones de
hojas verdes. Startup de Platanael. Hace
ciberseguridad en nube. Mayor compra en
historia de Google. Solo en impuestos.
Platanael en bolsa más de 3,000 millones
de hojas verdes. Pero no es caso único.
Nvidia compra Ran AI por 700 millones de
hojas verdes. También startup de
Platanael de inteligencia artificial.
Reguladores de plátanos unidos aprueban
sin pestañear. europeos también, porque
todos saben lo mismo. Sin ese software
sus máquinas rinden peor. Platanael no
exporta plátanos, exporta sistema que
protege plátanos de resto de monos,
vende seguridad, vende que monos hackers
no entren donde no deben, vende que todo
funcione, aunque mono poderoso intente
romperlo. Platanael capta 40% de toda
inversión privada de plátanos unidos en
ciberseguridad. 40% con menos de 10
millones de monos habitantes. Mono que
mira esos números piensa lo mismo que
siempre, que esas hojas verdes no son
para él, que eso es para empresas
gigantes, para monos con traje y
maletín. Pero XTB permite a cualquier
mono empezar a invertir desde cantidades
pequeñas. XTB es broker que sponsoriza
video de mono y permite invertir desde
0% de comisión sin pedir 100 documentos,
sin explicaciones de mono banquero que
habla raro. Abre cuenta en minutos y
explica cosas como si mono tuviera
cerebro de mono regulado en plataña y en
todas junglas latinas. Así que mono de
cualquier selva puede entrar. Diferencia
entre mono inversor y mono apostador es
simple. Mono apostador tira hojas verdes
y espera suerte. Mono inversor decide
antes de actuar. XTB obliga a hacer eso
con plan de inversión. Antes de invertir
primera moneda, Mono elige dónde va cada
hoja verde, cuánto riesgo acepta, qué
pasa si mercado cae. Plan primero, hojas
verdes después. Mono puede abrir cuenta
en XTV en enlace de descripción y
comentario fijado o escaneando QR en
pantalla. En 2025, startups de Platanael
levantaron más de 15,000 millones de
hojas verdes, 70% en ciberseguridad e
inteligencia artificial. No es
casualidad, no es racha de suerte, es
que llevan décadas construyendo
exactamente esto. Platanael sabe que si
empresa grande tiene problema de
seguridad, puede perder absolutamente
todo. Y empresa está dispuesta a
proteger su tesoro con millones de hojas
verdes. 396,000
monos trabajan en high tech en
Platanael, 10% de toda población, pero
ese 10% paga 25% de todos impuestos de
jungla. Son monos que sostienen sanidad,
infraestructura, ejército, todo. Pero
tecnología es solo una pata, porque
mientras Platanael construía
laboratorios, también construía otra
cosa. Y cuando jungla entra en
conflicto, cuando misiles vuelan, cuando
todo arde. Platanael es única jungla que
sabe exactamente qué hacer. Mono de
hierro. Platanael vive en guerra décadas
viendo como misiles de junglas enemigas
llegan por cielo, pero sistemas de
defensa interceptan casi 100% de
misiles. Mundo entero lo ve en
pantallas. Resultado es inmediato.
Demanda mundial de defensa aérea se
dispara como plátano lanzado desde rama
alta. Alemania compra sistema de
antimisiles hipersónico. 3,5,000
millones de hojas verdes. Reino Unido
quiere también Italia, países nórdicos.
Todos corren a Platanael. Todos quieren
escudos antimisiles. Platanael es
séptimo exportador de armas del mundo.
Cuando jungla europea se rearmaba por
Ucrania, Platanael se convierte en
proveedor que nadie puede rechazar. Y no
es solo defensa, bajo mar de Platanael
hay algo más. Campos Tamar y Leviatán.
Gas, muchísimo gas. Jungla europea
llevaba años pagando gas a jungla
equivocadas, dependiendo de jungla que
podía cortarle suministro cualquier
mañana. Entonces, Platanael abre grifo.
Jungla europea firma acuerdo. Pero
Platanael no solo quiere controlar
recursos de su jungla, quiere controlar
logística de medio mundo. Proyecto Imec,
ferrocarril que parte de jungla India,
cruza Arabia, cruza Jordania y llega a
puerto de Aifa, puerto de Platanael.
Desde allí todo sigue hacia jungla
europea. Se convertiría en ruta
comercial más importante de mundo. Eso
se llama infraestructura crítica. Hasta
aquí Platanael suena a jungla que tiene
todo controlado, pero hay estrecho de
agua, tan pequeño que en mapa casi no se
ve. Si paso se cierra, 20% de jugo de
dinosaurio mundial se queda atrapado y
cambia reglas de juego para Platanael.
Ormut en llamas. Febrero 2026. Plátanos
unidos y Platanael atacan jungla Irani.
Líder supremo muere. Teerán cierra
estrecho de Ormud. Eso se llama colapso
energético. Estrecho canaliza quinta
parte de petróleo de mundo. Pero no solo
eso, también quinta parte de gas natural
global pasa por allí. Precios se
disparan. Barril Brent sube de 70 a 110
en días. Monos analistas advierten que
podría llegar a 200. Inflación global
vuelve. República Popular Platanera
necesita petróleo. India también. Japón.
Corea del Sur. Importaciones tienen que
cruzar Ormud, pero están atrapadas. Mono
pensaba que crisis creada por Platanael
le perjudica, pero es contrario. Crisis
que destruye economía mundial refuerza a
Platanael. Demanda de defensa aérea
sube. Demanda de ciberseguridad sube.
Demanda de rutas alternativas sube. IMEC
ya no es proyecto teórico, es
supervivencia. Jungla europea necesita
gas que no sea de jungla rusa. Junglas
asiáticas necesitan rutas que no pasen
por Ormud. Platanael está en ambas.
Platanael es solución. Verdad no es
conspiración, es plan. Platana él no
domina por ser jungla grande, domina
porque se hizo imprescindible. Porque
cuando jungla entera entra en crisis,
todos necesitan lo que solo Platanael
tiene. Mientras tanto, en playa remota
de jungla desconocida, olas rompen
contra arena. abre un ojo, luego
otro. Ve cielo, ve palmeras, ve plátano
a medio comer a su lado. No sabe dónde
está, no sabe cómo llegó, no recuerda
nada, solo sabe una cosa. Algo gordo se
aproxima, no sabe qué, no sabe cuándo,
pero lo siente en los huesos. Warren
Moné ya lo advirtió. Jungla ha ardido
cuatro veces y siempre, siempre, antes
de crisis, mismas señales. ir a ver
video donde Mono revela cuáles son
señales para detectar si crisis real o
si es humo.